eur66 guérison miraculeuse
officiellement reconnu par l'église à
lourdes depuis 1858 7000 déclarations de
patients qui seraient guéris dans les
archives avant de déclarer qu'il y a
bien eu une intervention divine l'église
exige une enquête explications eléonore
gay et francis forger quelques pas
devant les journalistes pour attester du
prodige c'était en 1999 jean pierre bel
il venait d'être déclaré miraculé de
lourdes et ne se lassait pas de raconter
son histoire
c'est une chaleur qui me visiter qui
redonner vie à tous les membres de mon
corps à toutes les cellules de mme
encore en 1987
atteint de sclérose en plaques
lourdement handicapé il se rend à
lourdes
son état de santé s'améliore
soudainement est ce pour autant un
miracle si un signe ça veut dire la même
chose
mir accessing signe de la tendresse et
de miséricorde de dieu de toute sa
carrière cette neurologue n'a jamais été
témoin d'une guérison aussi
spectaculaire que celle de jean-pierre
belli elle reste sceptique
parfois on n'a pas d'explication c'est
pas pour ça qu'on veut qu'on a recours à
une explication divine mais parfois il
ya une telle mais c'est vrai en médecine
en général mais il ya encore une fois
dans la sclérose en plaques une telle
variabilité les intel 1 prédictibilité
du pronostic que voilà on dit voilà ce
qui compte c'est que les champs et bien
le docteur tellier et chef du bureau des
constatations médicales de lourdes
c'est lui qui a instruit le dossier ben
helli car pour toutes les déclarations
de guérison des malades 7000 en 120 en
l'église exige une enquête médicale
avant de se prononcer il faut d'abord
que le quai guérison faut que ces
guérisons inexpliquées par la médecine
et à partir de là on peut éventuellement
parler de mirage alors c'est l'église
catholique qui parlent de miracle
normalement officiellement dans la
mesure où elle y voit l'intervention de
dieu dans cet événement de guérison 66
guérisons ont été reconnus à lourdes
depuis 1858 le dr scellier pense qu'à
l'avenir
elles seront de moins en moins
fréquentes à cause des progrès de la
médecine